been to Buckingham Palace where Her
Majesty the Queen has asked me to form a
new government and I accept it in David
Cameron I follow in the footsteps of a
great modern Prime Minister under
David's leadership the government
stabilized the economy reduced the
budget deficit and helped more people
into work than ever before but David's
true legacy is not about the economy but
about social justice from the
introduction of same-sex marriage to
taking people on low wages out of income
tax altogether David Cameron has led a
one nation government and it is in that
spirit that I also plan to lead because
not everybody knows this but the full
title of my party is the conservative
and unionist party and that word
unionist is very important to me
it means we believe in the Union the
precious precious bond between England
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland but
it means something else that is just as
important
it means we believe in a union not just
between the nations of the United
Kingdom but between all of our citizens
every one of us whoever we are and
wherever we're from that means fighting
against the burning injustice but if
you're born poor you will die on average
nine years earlier than others if you're
black you're treated more harshly by the
criminal justice system than if you're
white if you're a white working-class
boy you're less likely than anybody else
in Britain to go to university if you're
at a state school you're less likely to
reach the top professions than if you're
educated privately if you're a woman you
will earn less than a man
if you suffer from mental health
problems there's not enough help to hand
if you're young you'll find it harder
than ever before to own your own home
but the mission to make Britain a
country that works for everyone
means more than fighting these in
Justices if you're from an ordinary
working-class family life is much harder
than many people in Westminster realize
you have a job but you don't always have
job security you have your own home that
you worry about paying the mortgage you
can just about manage but you worry
about the cost of living and getting
your kids into a good school
if you're one of those families if
you're just managing I want to address
you directly I know you're working
around the clock I know you're doing
your best and I know that sometimes life
can be a struggle the government I lead
will be driven not by the interests of
the privileged few but by yours we will
do everything we can to give you more
control over your lives when we take the
big calls we'll think not of the
powerful but you when we pass new laws
we'll listen not to the mighty but to
you when it comes to taxes we'll
prioritize not the wealthy but you when
it comes to opportunity
we won't entrench the advantages of the
fortunate few we will do everything we
can to help anybody whatever your
background to go as far as your talents
will take you we are living through an
important moment in our country's
history following the referendum we face
a time of great national change
and I know because we're Great Britain
that we will rise to the challenge as we
leave the European Union we will forge a
forge a bold new positive role for
ourselves in the world and we will make
Britain a country that works not for a
privileged few but for every one of us
that will be the mission of the
government I lead and together we will
build a better Britain